aisha your magazine sweet july
highlights
change makers which i just love and then
we heard about a flower shop in oklahoma
city that was changing the lives of the
homeless in their community
and then we thought maybe this is a
perfect match absolutely
okay let's meet them take a look
hi drew my name is rania and i'm jordan
we've been friends since elementary
school and together
we run curbside flowers back on
valentine's day in 2016
we along with the homeless alliance had
the idea to start creating and selling
bouquets of flowers
as a way to provide work and income to
people in our city
experiencing homelessness we've received
so much love and support from the
community
and at the same time we are raising
awareness and putting a face to the
issue of homelessness in oklahoma city
we want to help people see someone
beyond just the problem that they faced
flowers are beautiful and so are people
and if we work together as a community
we can help our neighbors in their
homelessness thanks drew
can't wait to talk to you soon
wow ronya and jordan are joining
aisha and i now hi guys
hi hi you guys thank you so much for
coming here today your operation looks
just
beautiful can you um explain the impact
um that your organization is having on
your
community right now curbside flowers
is a program of the homeless alliance
and we operate
just like any traditional flower shop
but we are a non-profit and we employ
people transitioning
out of homelessness in our community so
we are helping remove
barriers to employment for folks so that
they can earn
income build job skills and regain
stability in their lives
we have also teamed up with a local
college so that our participants can
earn
certifications which is such an
incredible experience for them
we employ 10 people in our flower shop
year round
but seasonally at valentine's day like
this week
we get to hire additional employees so
this valentine's day we are working with
45 additional people working to end
their home
wow and jordan you have a goal
this valentine's day right we do
our goal was to hit 2 000 bouquets
um and we are just a few hundred away
from that
what you guys are doing is so incredible
um and inspiring
and you guys yourselves are change
makers and so i i feel like
we we wanted to help you guys you know
meet that goal right drew
yes absolutely aisha um
ronya this valentine's day you set a
goal of the 2000 bouquets
and you said you were a few hundred off
right
yes we're a couple hundred away from
meeting that at this moment
well aisha and i would like to buy two
bouquets
and we'd like to pay five thousand
dollars for those bouquets
um just so that you
have um a little extra to get you where
you need to go and we're going to
feature you
on the drewberrymart.com website to
drive traffic to you
um this valentine's day
thank you guys so much so so much and
that
is incredible thank you so so much
excellent
and aisha you know when i look at your
and steph's body of work in the
philanthropic category
it is dauntingly incredible the impact
you are having
on you know the world at large your
country and your community uh
what is maybe when you do a change make
or highlight in your magazine
do you have any suggestions for someone
who just wants to do
one thing um in maybe their community
absolutely i feel like people always
feel like it needs to be so big
and grandiose and it really doesn't i i
truly believe in the cup of sugar model
so you know bringing that neighbor a cup
of sugar the small a small
axe like that so any small little thing
that you can do to help out your
community
because that person in turn is going to
bake a cake that's going to feed the
community
and so on and so forth and so it really
is a domino effect where one
small step to change can really actually
make a huge difference and so
never feel like any act of kindness or
change is too small
i so agree oh also ladies
um ronya and jordan i heard that um you
guys like flower home so i wanted to
give you a thousand dollar gift card
because you know flour flour flour
thank you so much so much that will
definitely go to good use in our office
space
perfect i just want to thank you guys
for joining aisha
and i and please go to our website at
thedrewmermartshow.com
to learn more about curbside flowers
thank you ladies
thank you and um
aisha i i have really been looking
forward
to meeting you thank you so much i
appreciate
it so much and you've inspired me um
and so i appreciate i appreciate the
kind words
and sweet july spring issue is out today
it is just incredible the full plate
also
best cookbook ever is available now you
probably already own it
um but if you're in the bay area stop by
aisha's suite july
shop and for more information on eat
learn play um
go to our website on the drewberrymore
show.com we'll have that all
up there and um before we all go we have
another galentine's day treat
all of our vffs are getting a hundred
dollar spa finder
gift card that can be redeemed for spa
services
and salons nationwide found
on spafinder.com so happy valentine's
day and thank you spa finder
aisha thank you for being here it's a
real honor